hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages
as they arrive and in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the observers chief leader writer
sonia soder and the political journalist
isabel oakshot thanks so much for
joining us ladies more from you both in
a moment uh let's see what is on
the front of some of those pages keep
taking the jab
says the pm as the trial has paused to
investigate clot reports the guardian's
headline referring to concerns over
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
that story also features in the
telegraph which says that a senior
government adviser has suggested that
the rollout of the astrazeneca jab
should be paused for young people until
regulators are certain
it's safe the metro hears from the boss
of easyjet who argues that at up to 420
pounds per person for a battery of cover
tests
only wealthy people will be able to
afford to go on foreign holidays this
summer
the mail understands the prime
minister's asked whether the tests can
be accessed
less expensively the express leads with
the pm sticking to the road map
despite warnings of a third wave
and according to the financial times the
investment bank goldman sachs spends 75
million pounds propping up shares in
deliveroo
after the takeaway firm had an
underwhelming debut on the london stock
exchange
last week well tonight we are joined by
sonia soder and isabel oak shot
uh thanks very much guys uh let's uh
start with
covid which inevitably is the main story
that we're talking about tonight uh on
the front of a lot of the pages
at sonia we're starting there with the
metro page one and this is
uh the boss of easyjet saying that it is
really gonna cost a fortune to go
traveling this year because of the cost
of covered tests
yes so the uh metro's looking at the
cost of tests to sort of go to popular
european destinations
and at the moment we're looking at sort
of between 300
and low 400 pounds per person
to go on holiday um and that's obviously
a significant amount of money for
families i mean to be honest
i wouldn't add 400 pounds on the cost of
my holiday
i wouldn't be going on holiday this
summer um i think
but i think you know there is a debate
that's going to rage about this
and i guess this is a question of
trade-offs really so we know that as our
vaccination program gets rolled out
it's going really well so far touchwood
it's certainly bringing down infection
rates
death rates all very good news but we
know that the biggest risk
in some ways uh to the progress we're
making would be
a more vaccine-resistant strain of the
virus
and um you know there is a certainly a
risk
of bringing one of those in from a
country abroad
who has um you know a less kind of
advanced i suppose
um a less progressed vaccine program uh
than we have
so i think there was a bit of a
trade-off here it's kind of like you
know do we want to sort of have
stricter controls on doing things like
going on holiday
and strict to sort of provisions around
testing etc
which means that lots of people won't be
able to afford to go on a holiday this
um
summer or do we want to sort of take the
risk and go on holiday but then actually
risk
way more economic damage later on and a
potential kind of
third wave where we don't have the
vaccines um against advice i think that
is kind of the trade-off which we're
dealing with
i sort of think most people would rather
forego their summer holiday
um than have the risk of another
lockdown
um so i personally think you know i'm
very happy to give up a summer holiday
if it means that we're safer and we
don't have to have
um another look down we don't have to
have more restrictions and it sort of
protects the progress that we've made
with with the um with the
with the vaccination programme it's hard
to say isn't it and i i know that there
will be some people who will say
actually they're willing to take the
risk because they would love a summer
holiday
uh isabel what are your thoughts about
the front of the metro i mean do you
think
that this is going to be a realistic
cost that will be passed on to travelers
or do you think this is just
scaremongering on behalf of easyjet
no i mean the reality is that these
tests are ridiculously expensive and it
would be very interesting to know
who is making all the money out of it i
mean sonia quoted figures of three or
four hundred pounds
as it happens i'm fairly recently back
from a very long period away
with my family and coming back into the
uk and meeting all the testing
requirements
cost me probably about 1400 pounds and
that's for four of us
three children and myself and that's not
including the cost of the testing
before we traveled now i don't for a
minute say that it's not important to
have those tests of course people should
be
testing negative before they get on
planes but the reality is that other
countries provide these tests for 30 40
50 pounds not 200 pounds so this is
ripoff britain
and i think we need to look at why these
tests can't be provided much more
cheaply
and then of course as the issue of the
long quarantine that's required when you
return again a very important thing but
i think it's immensely off-putting
i certainly won't be booking a foreign
holiday this summer with any
confidence or enthusiasm i think i would
just stay in the uk
because it's just not realistic and at
any point the government may change the
status of your destination
i mean sonia in terms of the cost of
these tests i mean as somebody with kids
at school
we we're offered two free tests per
family member per week
as well as the child so the government
seems happy
on one hand to provide free tests for
huge sways of the population also saying
they want all the population to be
tested twice a week
why then can't those tests be used as
as your test when you go abroad and you
test when you come back
well if i understand that there's a
difference between the tests so i think
the test that you get when your child's
at school
are lateral flow tests so their tests
that give a really quick result but they
are less accurate
uh than the pcr the gold standard tests
that are what's used to test people when
they're coming back from traveling
i think that's absolutely right and
appropriate actually it's much more
important to get kids back to school
than people go on a summer break
and we're taking a risk with kids going
back to school and using pcr tests and
that is okay
it's a calculated risk it's one that we
need to take because it's so important
to have children back in school
i personally don't feel the way about
summer holidays and i think probably
most of the country doesn't isabel
it is the front of the mail that boris
johnson seems to believe that he can
make these tests these gold
standard pcr tests cheaper um if they
were cheaper
would that encourage you to maybe think
about it or would the quarantine still
put you up well you can make them
cheaper because other countries are
doing it i mean there i know that for a
fact that they're available for 30 40
50 pounds of pop elsewhere as opposed to
four times that amount here
so you know absolutely it ought to be
possible to come to an
arrangement where they are provided at
that kind of level
but i just think it's far too risky i
mean you know the government doesn't
give a lot of notice before changing the
status of countries and that's because
they have to be
quite fleet of foot according to what's
going on in
individual countries and their own
emergent
strains that the government is picking
up on so
i just think it's far too high risk and
it is awful and it's
deeply disappointing that people can't
go away but it does seem to me too risky
and i just think reading between the
lines
it's not really going to be a viable
option for most people
this side of the autumn well certainly
not if it's 400 pounds per person and
you've got you've got a family
and let's move on to the guardian now
this also talking
about uh covert but but looking at the
efficacy of the astrazeneca jab and of
course this evening
sonia we've heard that the tests on
children are being paused
uh astrazeneca are saying that they
haven't got concerns but that they just
it's belt and braces they're just going
to pause it and wait for a few days
until
they hear from the regulator yeah and i
understand why people might feel
concerned if they hear this but i don't
think people should feel concerned
you know this is a precaution it's
absolutely the right thing to do
um while the mhra is exploring these
incredibly rare cases it has to be said
of of clots and you know so as a
precaution there's
that they're pausing the pediatric trial
and i think you know that's right no one
would want it to go ahead
but it doesn't mean that the astrazeneca
vaccine
is is dangerous for example i think the
experts are very clear that at the
moment the mrh
mhra so our medical regulator the world
health organization
other international medical regulators
are saying that the benefits
of out of sort of rolling out
the astrazeneca vaccine far outweigh any
small risks
a lot of vaccines come with very tiny
risks sometimes of quite serious um
disorders we're still learning about
astrazeneca but the number of cases are
absolutely
tiny and the benefits are immense
so i think you know the mhra is looking
at the data
they're understanding it you know
there's a chance at some point in the
future
they may make a different decision for
example for particular age groups but
that's not where they are yet
and you know i trust the experts
involved with the
medical regulator and isabel i mean do
you think this is going to put people
off it's certainly not the case you know
when you rock up at your
your surgery or wherever it is you're
able to go and get your vaccine that you
get to pick which one you have
but it is it is a problem for
for the the reputation of the of the
vaccine isn't it it does seem that
absolutely looking at the politics of
this if i were in downing street tonight
i would be pretty concerned about the
headlines in
tomorrow's papers and the very fact that
we're talking about it here
people aren't going to hear the
vanishingly tiny statistical chances
something like 1 in 2.5 million we think
of any kind of complication relating to
blood clots they're just going to hear
possible side effects involving blood
clots and that vaccine and i think it
will
absolutely add to the fears that some
people already have
about a vaccine they think has been
rushed through just an instinctive thing
so i think there are real concerns about
really the amount of publicity
uh that is being given to the the
halting of this trial
and it being somewhat sensationalized
because of course sonia i mean
the risk of a very very small risk of
blood clots exists in all sorts of
different medications that the people
might take
um do you are you concerned sonja about
the fact that this
vaccine was developed as the vaccine
that was going to be
sold at cost it was going to help the
developing world
do you think there is it now a danger
that some countries might turn their
noses up at it
well i think we've already seen some
countries actually politicking about it
we've seen emmanuel
macron talking about astrazeneca which i
think
is really to be deplored to be honest
i'm sorry i'm thinking more about
developing world countries you know
not necessarily the countries that have
you know got the ability to choose and
afford them i think most countries will
look
at the record of the vaccine and will
very much
kind of want it i think it's an amazing
thing that it's been developed to be
sold at cost
i think you know isabel raises a there's
a really interesting point here which is
about
how upfront are you with the public
about you know
the the what's going on with this
vaccine and with vaccine trials and i
think
you do need to be up front because
otherwise um
you know people feel like there's
something being covered up it would be
awful if the pediatric trial
was suspended for example and it wasn't
reported but word got out and people
thought that there were
was a conspiracy theory but you have to
quite finally judge that because i think
you really have to be honest with the
public but you have to have
experts on tv talking about
how small the chances are and how
actually
lots of vaccines have very small chances
very very tiny chances of side effects
but the benefits far far far
outweigh the risks so i i do think
there's there is a tricky thing here
isabelle's right around
public health communications how are you
completely upfront and truthful with the
public
while at the same time keeping risks in
proportion
i think that is genuinely quite a
difficult public health communication
and it is so important you're absolutely
right um well lots more to come uh
after the break coming up we're going to
be talking a little bit about vaccine
passports is that the way to get the
hospitality sector and the economy
will broadly up and running we'll
discuss that next
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now sonia soder and
isabel oakshot and we're going to kick
off this half with the inside of the
financial times isabel
and this is about well some people call
them vaccine passports others call them
immunity certificates
this is about whether or not uh having a
bit of paper that says that that you are
pretty safe either from passing on
covert catching it is going to become
part of normal life
will it do you think well i was quite
struck by this editorial in the
ft particularly the way they call it
immunity certificates as if that's some
kind of slightly softer way of
describing
what is potentially a very insidious
measure
the ft of course represents all sorts of
uh business communities the majority of
whom
and this is of course a generalization
are anti the idea of people having to
show
an immunity certificate or rather a
vaccine passport
to access for example hospitality
cinemas theaters sports stadiums and so
on but the ft is arguing
that this is a sort of necessary evil if
you like in fact they're actually softer
than that they seem to sort of
slightly shrug off all the concerns
about this system
and say actually you know this is a
reasonable price to pay for getting back
to some form of normality
i think a lot of people can get their
heads around the idea of having
a vaccine passport for international
travel and if it would spare us
all those costly covered tests and
quarantining
then i could see the upside in that but
i think there are real deep concerns
about requiring it for access to many
other things
and i think it has the potential to
become very
socio-economically divisive and
regressive
and there's a huge political row brewing
over this
very substantial opposition to it on the
tory benches and still pretty unclear
where labour stands on it a lot of
flip-flopping going on there
so do you think it's an insidious
measure
so i'm a lot more sympathetic to this
idea than isabelle i'm very sympathetic
to it in principle
i think if it allows us to open up more
quickly
you know i've got no problem i've not
obviously been vaccinated yet um
well not obviously but i but i am just
because you're so fabulously young
stop rubbing it in i just realized
well you know you never know what
medical conditions people have etc but i
haven't been vaccinated yet but i've got
no problem
with people who have been vaccinated
getting access to things like pubs
before me
i guess i do have a couple of practical
concerns and i think this is actually
why labour hasn't come out with a clear
line yet because
it wants to see how these practical
things would work so first of all i do
think there are probably
some quite significant privacy concerns
around this
and do we trust the government with this
incredibly sensitive data
um sort of so i think there's that
question and secondly i just think
my god the the kovada last summer was so
bad
so i just do wonder if there's a
competency
issue here can the government get this
right but in principle
i'm not opposed to it but it's about i
mean
those are the kind of the the logistical
practical reasons that people are
against but is
you are against it much much more
morally it seems i mean
there are those who will say well look
you know you only need one of these if
you're going somewhere out of choice you
don't
you don't don't need this to go to the
supermarket you don't need to go to the
shops as if you're going to a
to a concert if you're going to
somewhere that you want to go it's not
something that's being forced on people
is it
well it couldn't be forced on people
because that would be against all human
rights legislation i mean this is what
came out of nuremberg
they can't do that but i don't think
that's any great reassurance and
i don't think we should shrug off the
practicalities i mean
thinking about the time frame of this it
would be entirely unreasonable to
introduce this before everybody has been
offered the vaccine and i don't think
that's going to be
realistically until everyone's had both
jabs it's not going to be until at least
the autumn
and then when the vast majority of the
population have had their jobs anyway i
don't really see
why it would be needed so i think it is
the wrong solution to a problem that
hopefully
won't actually exist except in terms of
international travel